all right up next is gonna be Scott hey
Scott welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave pleasure to speak with ya
you two men how can I help so my wife
and I before we started your program we
went and got ourselves a 30-year fixed
mortgage that we can now that we're
aware of your program we're paying it at
a 15-year good it's about 35% of our
take-home pay okay we really like the
house but now we just found out my
wife's pregnant
their first child thank you
we both want her to stay home good but
that's gonna that's going to take our
income down and it's going to put our
mortgage at about 45% of our take-home
pay mm-hmm
would you suggest that we should move
yes you out that we could afford okay
yes unless your income unless your
incomes going to go way up real quickly
it's gonna go up I've had this talk with
my manager I said where do you see me in
ten years and he said he can put me up
another 10,000 over time but I don't
know how soon that's going to be what do
you make so I'm making 55,000 right now
okay here's the thing when your house
payment is half of your take-home pay
your there's two problems number one
everything's destabilized because it's
like it's like you're walking around
carrying 300 pounds on your back you can
do it if you're strong but every little
bump in the road causes you to trip and
fall and break your face you know it's
just you know what I'm saying it's just
the way that you just added this immense
weight and so it destabilizes is number
one problem number two problem is you're
poor you're house poor you don't have
any money to do any wealth building you
don't have any money to buy the next car
you don't have any money to fund kids
college you don't have any money and so
yeah I think her coming home if that's
her desire is a great choice but it
probably doesn't mean she's coming home
to that house right now you don't have
to sell the house immediately
you might try it for a year if you want
to and just see how things go but you
know I think you're gonna find that what
I'm saying is true you're gonna feel
like you're walking around with 300
pounds of feed sacks on your back yeah
we we ran the budget out and we can make
it work but that's exactly right
like we have very little wiggle room at
the end of everything yeah you're on the
end of a razor I mean you're walking
around behind of a razor and it's just
it's just it's not sustainable you can
pull it off for a little while
but long term you're going to be
destabilized and be unable to build
wealth and do life well and it's not
going to be worth it just for a stupid
house so you could try for a little you
know go ahead and have the baby come
home talk about moving in the first year
that she's home or something like that
and really watch her budget but don't
you dare call me back a year after the
baby and go well you know we were in a
bunch of credit card debt because we
weren't watching her budget and she came
home and we didn't make it work okay
fair enough you got it hey thanks for
the call man and congratulations on the
new baby it's worth the sacrifice to be
in a smaller home to have a good life
and mom be at home with the baby if
that's what moms call is and sounds like
it is in this lady's life so very very
cool thank you for joining us